hi there steve coffin here
this will be the last in this in this
series of steve summer sessions where i
answer your questions that you submitted
via twitter with the
hashtags ask steve
i'm going to answer a question that
comes up all the time
and i'm going to try to touch on a few
others that
were also raised by
some of you who follow this series the
main
subject therefore of my
little video here is how long does it
take to learn a language
this question is asked often and in
different ways
one person asked how long does it take
to get from
uh a2 to c2 for example i think his
question was uh
you may be familiar with the common
european framework
levels for languages
if not you can google for it
a is beginner b is intermediate and c is
advanced and i have a1 a2 b1 b2 c1 c2
so
how long how long does it take well
first of all it depends what you want to
achieve if all you want to do is to be
able to say a few things like hello my
name is and so forth it doesn't take
very long it can take you you know no
time really
to do that you won't understand much of
what is said back to you but you can at
least say a few things
and that has some value
but i'm going to talk today primarily
about getting to fluency and if you
remember my previous video i said that
fluency just means getting to where
you're comfortable
so i think that on the european scale b2
somewhere between b2 and c1 is fluency
c2 is means you're absolutely excellent
i wouldn't say flawless but that you can
basically you never have situations
where you can't express yourself that's
c2
b2 c1 to me to my mind is fluency how
long does it take to get there well
i think i'm going to illustrate this
by referring to my own experience as a
language learner
um
the i won't talk about french because i
had french at school even though i
didn't really speak much french until i
got motivated but then i also spent
three years in france as a student
studying in french and so forth so
that's a rather special case
chinese was the next language
and i studied chinese in hong kong
which is not a chinese speaking
environment so
mostly what i did was i had three hours
a day of of one to one
with chinese teachers and then i just
spent a lot of time listening and
reading
i think that i studied six seven hours a
day because i did very little else other
than yeah i played some tennis i would
go jogging i would have obviously i'd
eat
but i'd often eat listening to my tape
recorder um
and i'd have you know social activities
uh out with friends this kind of thing
but i think i spent about 2 000 hours
in sort of 10 11 months i spent about 2
000 hours at the end of this period
i was able to write the british foreign
service exam
uh you know i had to write
an essay in chinese translate newspaper
editorials from chinese into english
from english into chinese had to write a
diplomatic note in chinese i had an oral
exam in chinese
and i think i probably was at a c1 level
two thousand hours now since that time i
had
lots of opportunity to use chinese i've
visited china perhaps a dozen times
i know chinese people here in vancouver
so i've i don't know how many hours i've
spoken but i've spoken quite a bit and
my chinese has improved although
recently i've spoken less so the chinese
have probably fallen off a bit
two thousand hours
i should point out that i did better
than the other students largely because
i aggressively sought out content to
read more than listening because in
those days we had these big clumsy tape
recorders
didn't have the modern mp3 player
uh but i sought out for chinese
books with glossaries because i didn't
want to use a dictionary it's just too
clumsy and there were lots of these
readers on politics on history on
literature on geography and so forth and
i think i read five times as much as any
other student
and i think that was the secret to my
success
two thousand dollars for chinese all
right russian i spent five years about
an hour a day
largely listening
uh
and working at link
link in those days was very slow and
clumsy so it was a lot less efficient
than it would be today
but i think i spent 2000 hours over the
five years
what level am i i think in russia i'm
more like a b2
with relatively little practice in
speaking
probably i have a larger vocabulary in
russian than in chinese
if i had an opportunity to speak more to
use the language if i were in russia for
even a month
i think that my
russian would improve and i could reach
a c1 level with a lot of additional uh
practice speaking but my comprehension
of spoken russian of written russian is
probably at a c1 level
so 2000 hours spread over spread over
five years
uh both of those languages are difficult
in the sense that there's relatively
little common vocabulary with
english
russian is more complicated in terms of
grammar
chinese has other problems such as
learning the characters dealing with
tones
but building vocabulary in chinese is
easier once you know
enough characters
check was the next language and uh
because of russian because the structure
is very similar in czech is very similar
to russian and about fifty percent of
the vocabulary in czech is identifiable
through russian it went more quickly and
i would think that i spent about 500
hours on
check
and my check is probably b1 although
again i think i read and understand
spoken check at a b2 level
but that's 500 hours
um
i should say that
you know now that i can only study an
hour or two a day
it's my experience and i felt the same
when i was studying chinese that the
more concentrated you study the better
the faster you learn if you can put in
eight hours a day that's over
uh one year that's better than one hour
a day over eight years that you will
forge these new
neural networks in your brain
more quickly if you do it that way
i apologize for the noise outside here
um
so check was 500 hours i would say that
romanian i probably spent about 150
hours and my romanian is such that i was
able to carry on
halfway
uh comprehensively conversations in
romania i can read the newspaper i'm
probably at a b-1 level in romanian
but i i think that if i put in another
150 hours i could very quickly be at a
b2 level in romanian
and the reason why it's much faster with
romanian is obviously because
70 percent of the vocabulary is similar
to italian and french
and the structure is similar to other
latin languages but it does have a
number of things that are specific to
romanian that you have to learn
korean i probably spent 300 hours
and uh i still think i'm a
a2 in korean i don't understand the
language as well i understand romanian
very well korean is more difficult uh
korean has structural things has uh
a number of issues that make it more
difficult
uh
so
i guess in summary then the simple
answer to the question is
it'll take it depends how
well you want to speak the language is
the goal b1 b2 c1 c2
that's point number one and point number
two it depends on how similar the
language is to your own
but if i were to generalize i would say
that for a difficult language
2 000 hours for an easy language 1 000
hours now how difficult or how easy the
language is depends on which languages
you already speak so you kind of have a
continuum continuum there somewhere
between 1 000 and 2 000 hours that you
need to spend
and the more concentrated the time you
can apply to it the better
i'm talking about spending time with the
language so i don't necessarily think it
matters whether you spend the time in a
classroom or reading or listening
or
doing other activities it's time spent
with the language i think different
people have different preferences
it's also more convenient to arrange
listening so at the present time i
mostly do
listening
one other comment
unless you have a specific reason for
wanting to know how long it takes
i find the process of learning language
enjoyable i try to do things that are
enjoyable
that's why i focus on listening
and reading and listening to and reading
things that interest me so i'm learning
about czech history or russian history
or romanian history or politics while
i'm learning the language so it's an
enjoyable process i'm not anxious to get
to the end of it
but if you wanted a plan then that's
what i would plan on
and so for example in my own case if i
look forward to the next 20 years i'll
be 68 in october
uh you know i think that depending on
the language a year or two or three
with the amount of time that i will have
available to spend
will be enough to learn a language easy
languages less than a thousand for
example polish would probably take me
five six hundred hours or dutch
if i wanted to go after those easier
languages on the other hand arabic hindi
turkish are probably probably going to
take me closer to 2000 hours
and so i think that over the next 20
years i'll have time to learn all of
those languages and more
a couple of other questions that i want
to touch on briefly here
one person asked do you think it's
useful to use a dictionary
which has roman letters and presumably
this is for learning
uh
asian languages
um i
personally believe that
the dictionary is there to give you a
quick sense of the meaning of the word i
don't study dictionaries so i want a
quick sense of the meaning
generally that means a bilingual
dictionary
uh
trouble with monolingual dictionaries is
very often the explanation
uh contains words that i don't know and
i don't want to spend my time looking up
more words and more words and more words
in order to eventually figure out the
meaning of a word i want to get back to
the context to the content that i'm
reading so that i can enjoy it and let
all of this natural language come into
me so i don't think really matters
whatever you're comfortable using in the
way of dictionaries is fine
another question is how how high a level
do you need
in order to work abroad
well it depends entirely on the job if
you're going to be a waiter or a busboy
in a hotel
doing some manual labor probably a sort
of a2 level is sufficient
um if you're working for a foreign
company in a foreign country you
probably need c2 if you're working in
that environment
if you are simply a representative of a
company traveling into other countries
then probably b2c1 is sufficient
another question was
is it possible to achieve native-like
pronunciation if this comes up all the
time
i've heard actors and actresses
who are british and speak with an
american accent or americans who speak
with a british accent and i can't tell
that they're not british or american
i have heard foreigners speak
english without an accent
i can only really judge english speakers
if i hear lucca speak french or german
or spanish he sounds native to me
but that's really only for a native
speaker to judge he doesn't sound native
to me in english so my quick answer is
it's possible it's extremely rare and
it's not necessary
another question was uh how much because
i i often refer to my listening
activities as a major
form of of sort of language learning
activity how much do you have to
understand when you listen in my case i
like to understand 75 to 80 percent uh
it's often less than that but then i
want to have
uh text available that i can read
so that's why if echo muskv that's why
uh
cesky roslas link places where you can
get
uh text to go with the audio are so
important because that way you can read
it you can learn the words you can
listen again and get yourself to where
you understand 75 to 80
i don't like to just listen to the
language and not understand what's going
on although some people claim that it is
beneficial
okay i hope i have covered all i wrote
some notes down here
um yeah i think i've covered everything
i hope i have
if you have any other questions send
them along i can try to answer them
during my regular videos and we may have
another series sometime in the future
thank you very much bye for now
you